peu
[Musique]
je me baladais sur l'avenue le coeur
ouvert à d'inconnus j'avais envie de
dire bonjour à n'importe qui n'importe
qui et celui toi je t'ai dit n'importe
quoi
il suffisait de te parler pour pas
proposer aux champs elysées
oh
[Musique]
on change les airs
au soleil sous la pluie à midi
à minuit et à tout ce que vous voulez au
champs elysées tu m'a dit j'ai rendez
vous dans un sous sol avec des fous qui
vivent la guitare à la main du soir au
matin allant jeter accompagnés pour la
chanter on a dansé et là n'a même pas
pensé à s'embrasser aux chandelles
[Applaudissements]
aux champs-elysées
au soleil sous la pluie à midi
à minuit il ya tout ce que vous voulez
aux champs elysées
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
m
hier soir deux inconnus et ce matin sur
l'avenue deux amoureux tout étourdi par
la longue
et bonne étoile à la con comme un
orchestre a vu le corps tous les oiseaux
du point-du-jour chante l'amour au
changé
aux champs elysées
au soleil
sous la pluie à midi
et les
ce que vous voulez changer les
au chant d'ailés
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]
aux champs elysées
sous la pluie à miner
il y à tout ce que vous voulez aux
champs elysées
m
oh
[Musique]